قال ديوان رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه ان
بنيامين نتنياهو اوعز للجيش الاسرائيلي
باعداد خطه مزدوجه تشمل مسارا لاجلاء
الفلسطينيين في منطقه رفح وسحق كتائب حركه
حماس هناك واشار الديوان في بيان مقتضب
الى انه لا يمكن تحقيق اهداف الحرب في غزه
دون سحق الكتائب الاربعه التابعه لحماس
والتي تعمل في رفح لكن عمليه عسكريه كبيره
هناك لا يمكن ان تتم دون اجلاء السكان من
مناطق القتال وفق البيان وياتي هذا الموقف
الاسرائيلي ردا على موقف الاداره
الامريكيه التي اعلنت رفضها لعمليه
اسرائيليه واسعه النطاق في
رفح انت تلابي مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس قراءه ربما في هذا الاعلان
الاخير هو واضح بان هذا الاعلان الرسمي من
ديوان رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه ياتي ردا
على
تصريحات المتحدث بلسان البيت الابيض جون
كيربي الذي قال بالامس بانه بان الاداره
الامريكيه لا يمكنها ان تقبل عمليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه في منطقه رفح وانه لا توجد لدى
الاداره الامريكيه ايه معلومات عن نيه
اسرائيل القيام بعمليه
عسكريه واسعه النطاق في تلك المنطقه في
حاليا وبالتالي رد ديوان رئاسه الوزراء
ياتي على هذه التصريحات على وجه الخصوص
لكن ديوان رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه يريد
ان يؤكد على ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا
يمكنها ان تحقق اهداف الحرب التي اعلنتها
في القضاء على حركه حماس دون القضاء على
الكتائب الاربع المتبقيه في منطقه رفح
لكنها بطبيعه الحال كما يقول بيان تاخذ
بعين الاعتبار ان عمليه كهذه سوف تتطلب
اجلاء المدنيين الفلسطينيين من تلك
المنطقه ليس فقط من يسكنون في تلك المنطقه
انما ايضا عشرات الاف النازحين
الفلسطينيين الذين نزحوا قصرا من المناطق
الشماليه لقطاع غزه اي في الى هذه المنطقه
على وجه الخصوص لذلك بيان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وديوان رئاسه الوزراء يقول
على ان بنيامين نتنياهو اوعز للجيش
الاسرائيلي حاليا اعداد خطه من
مسارين يتضمن المسار الاول خطه لعمليه
الاجلاء الواسعه التي سوف تكون في تلك
المنطقه والمسار الثاني الذي يتعلق بسير
العمليات العسكريه الجباره التي سوف تقوم
هناك بحسب وصف البيان ولكن علينا ان ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار ان التهديد المتسارع في عم
من جانب الحكومه الاسرائيليه لعمليه
مرتقبه في منطقه رفح هو ياتي ايضا على
الاقل حاليا في اطار محاوله الضغط او
يستخدم كورقه ضغط ايضا على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لا سما وان هذا الحديث
المتزايد عن عمليه في رفع ياتي في خضم
المفاوضات التي ما زالت مستمره من اجل
ابرام صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرى وكان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تريد ان تضغط على
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتقول لها بانه ليس
لدى المقاومه الفلسطينيه مكان لوضع شروط
او انها ليست في موضع من يمكن ان يضع
شروطا لاسرائيل من اجل اتمام صفقه جديده
وهي تلوح بورقه القيام بعمليه عسكريه واسه
في رفح من اجل ربما تليين مواقف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في هذا السياق لكن من ناحيه
اخرى نحن راينا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي تردد
في البدايه في القيام بعمليه عسكريه في
خانيونس وبعد انتهاء الهدنه قام بعمليه
عسكريه واسعه النطاق هناك وهو يسعى الان
كما يبدو لاعداد خطه من اجل توسيعها الى
تلك المناطق لكن من ناحيه اخرى ليس فقط
الموقف الامريكي هو الموقف المعارض لعمليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه جباره كما توصف في
اسرائيل في تلك المناطق انما ايضا مصر
ترفض هذا جمله وتفصيلا على اعتبار ان
العمليه العسكريه سوف تكون قريبه من
الحدود المصريه ومصر تعارض ذلك وهي تخشى
ان يؤدي ذلك الى حركه نزوح كبيره ايضا من
جانب الفلسطينيين الى داخل الاراضي
المصريه وهنالك مخاوف ايضا من الجانب
المصري ومن الاداره الامريكيه ان عمليه
عسكريه كبيره في منطقه رفح سوف تؤ ثر بشكل
كبير على مساله ادخال المعونات الانسانيه
الى داخل قطاع غزه على اعتبار ان منطقه
رفح و معبر رفع هو المعبر الوحيد الذي
تدخل منه البضائع والمساعدات الى داخل
قطاع غزه لذلك راينا في المقابل بالامس ان
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي عرض خطه جديده
لادخال المعونات والمساعدات الانسانيه الى
قطاع غزه من المناطق الشماليه عبر معبر
كارني في المنطقه الشرقيه ومعبر ايرس في
المناطق الشماليه لكن هذا الامر يتطلب
كثيرا من الاعداد كما يبدو سفيان شكرا لك
الياس
كرام